hello everyone I asked Chad GPT to
recreate the story of the Little Red
Riding Hood by replacing the wolf with
Magnus Carlsen and this is what it came
up with uh the Little Red Riding Hood
was on a journey to her grandmother's
house carrying a basket of chess pieces
but be careful her mother warned the
world chess champion Magnus Carlsen is
known to be wandering around the forest
and he is a fierce player he will try to
challenge you to your game and if you
lose he will eat you she met Magnus
Carlsen the world cheers Champion
wandering in the forest he challenged
her to a game of chess promising to let
her go if she wins she accepted using
her grandmother's teachings to outsmart
Carlson winning the game Carlson
impressed buyer skills gave her advice
to keep practicing and studying chess
and from that day on the Little Red
Riding Hood became an avid chess player
even challenging Carlson to a rematch
and winning again that's the story The
End